hey Nico I've been wanting to talk to  you all day I wanted to get everybody  back together  and I know that it can't be like it was  the truth I miss you guys the bell the  big machine I hope you're right about  this not being a big deal the last thing  they're interested in is what their  parents are doing you gonna let us in  are they  why is my mom's purse here what kind of  charity meeting is this a lot of our  parents are who we thought something  really weird is going on  I have so many questions no matter what  we are we can't let our parents keep  getting away with this stuff  you cannot let anyone but a mind what  we're doing  [Music]  we're gonna need it another sacrifice  kids are living on borrowed time  [Music]  we have to stop this no one else will  [Music]  I'll shut out what's destructed around  you look at me  [Music]  you